les défis du renouvelable ce matinlà
parents et enfants avaient décidé de les
relever à la Maison de l'Environnement
de Manil et h petits et grands étaient
atablés autour des trois ateliers Solair
éolien et thermique ce matin on avait
envie de montrer ou de en tout cas
d'apprendre aux enfants de façon très
simple quelles sont les énergies
renouvelables que l'on peut utiliser
pourah essayer de trouver d'autres
solutions que le pétrole ou les énergies
fossiles nos ingénieurs d'un jour ont pu
bâtir leur première maison carton avec
panneaux photovoltaïqu des véhicules
hydrauliques ou à air comprimé et
participer à la course de voiture au
début il viennent vraiment plus pour
jouer qu'autre chose mais très vite ils
comprennent que ça a une utilité et que
ça permet justement bah de remplacer des
énergies fossiles par des énergies
simples et des énergies naturel qui sont
le soleil le vent et l'eau l'eau le vent
n'ont désormais plus de secret pour ces
apprentis écolos les petits comme les
grands je trouvais c'était un super
atelier pour les enfants aussi bien pour
les enfants que les adultes c'est
vraiment ils ont fait beaucoup de Ch
chose une maison regardez donc hein tu
peux décrire l'omé ce que tu as fait un
petit peu non ouais ce qui t'a plu
exactement faire la maison ah j'ai
réalisé une voiture et une
voiture avec qui marche avec de l'air
avec un moulin à
eau et la
voit en fait là faut souffler dans la
paille et après grâce au ball ça ça
donne une impulsion après l' sort et ça
fait avancer la voiture prochaine
atelier le 15 décembre pour des
décorations de Noël à base de matériaux
de
récupération